With summer heat and hot temps, you wanna make sure to drink plenty of water.
But why not add a little flavor to your glass with simple and refreshing creations.
Hi guys, I'm Krystin Goodwin with Buzz60,...
...and here are a few tips to infuse your water with flavor and stay hydrated this summer.
Fruit is a healthy and easy way to add taste to your water.
Just rinse and slice the fruit,...
...and use as much or as little as you'd like to create the taste you're looking for.
For a light flavor with a kick,...
...throw pieces of ginger root, mint leaves and lime juice into a blender.
Then just add water for a crisp and refreshing taste.
If you're looking for a citrusy blend,...
...mix oranges, grapefruit, lemon and lime into a blender.
Then add the mixture to your water for a robust taste that's loaded with vitamin C.
But if you're looking for a full-on fruity taste,...
...take cherries, lime and mint.
Mix in to your water for a cherry lime drink with a minty twist.
So stay refreshed this season and spice up your water with these spa-tastic blends.
It'll taste great to hydrate.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.